the number of flu deaths this season is
more than double what it was at the same
time last year 8 year olds I net moment
is one of the latest victims of this
outbreak
she died Tuesday night in Alabama the
Centers for Disease Control and
Prevention says at least 759 people have
died from the influenza virus since
October 7th and last year there were 322
flu deaths at the same time the virus
has been killing more than 100 people a
week since mid-december dr. taryn rulers
here at the table terror good morning
this is so troubling when you put the
numbers in perspective it is good
morning to you Gayle you know the CDC
says the rate of hospitalizations for
the flu has doubled since December
health officials and families are trying
to spread the warning that the virus
does not discriminate as the season
continues to worsen from the time the
whole thing started time we knew
anything was wrong the time he was gone
was was less than hour and a half that's
how fast Steven Teresa down away say
their son Tyler died they say the
eight-year-old collapsed at home just a
day after being diagnosed with the flu
flipped him over on his back and his
lips were blue so we called 911
instantly Tyler who was also diagnosed
with autism and a speech disorder called
apraxia suffered heart failure and
couldn't be resuscitated even at the
hospital his parents say he was our only
child and he was the light of our world
the flu kills thousands of people of all
ages every year seeing widespread flu
throughout all 50 states dr. Lisa
mariga's senior director of infection
prevention at Johns Hopkins University
says some people need to be especially
careful the higher risk groups the very
young those over 65 years old and people
with underlying medical conditions
should seek medical care and get the
antiviral medications flu complications
can include infection in the lungs like
pneumonia from there
patients can develop sepsis a
life-threatening complication that can
cause blood pressure to drop organs to
fail and even death the exact cause of
Tyler's death is being examined but his
mother never believed it could be from
the flu I thought we would get over it
and be back to
school by Friday I just never imagined
him not here anymore federal health
officials anticipate this year's flu
season will continue for at least ten to
twelve more weeks besides getting a flu
shot the best way to prevent the spread
of the virus is to wash your hands
especially if you are around those who
are infected Tara thank you